[Music]
welcome to sog cast number five my name
is john streicher meyer i'll be your
host tonight and joining me will be
mystery technician tom
thank you for joining us
on the night
of august the 23rd 1968 in the morning
more than 100 sappers hit
fob-4
a green beret top-secret operational
base in da nang it was just north of
marble mountain
during that attack it came after
midnight it was a moonless night
and the
tap sappers who were highly trained nba
soldiers hit the base
and
up on the mountain there had been a
recon team up there spike team
rattler
and we'll take it from here from the
book on the ground up in the north face
of marble mountain
st rattler was providing security for
fob4
by acting as an early warning element
but they too were caught unaware by the
surprise attack
assistant team leader larry trimble
monitored the desperate disjointed
and chaotic
chatter that is coming over his radio
s t ratler was suddenly attacked by a
group of sappers who had made their way
undetected to the entrance of the team's
observation point
attainable only by climbing ropes hung
on the steep mountainside
before trimble could think about how
they had done it
grenades began detonating all around the
st's small perimeter
several team members were hit by
shrapnel
but the veteran recon men immediately
responded with a savage fuselage a car
15 fire
and grenades of their own
dropping them down on the approaching
nba the north vietnamese army
and stopping the assault cold
the observation point overlooked the
entire dna compound to the north
by the light of the flares now dropping
from the sky
spike team rattler could see human
beings scurrying
about like cockroaches
the americans and their chinese team
members watched in disbelief and
frustration
as the well-orchestrated attack
developed
wave after unrelenting wave of nva
sappers
swept in through the east and the side
of the compound
that faced the south china sea
as they flooded the compound buildings
exploded in their wake dead bodies were
left lying dark stains in this clean
white sand
it was clear the enemy had achieved
total surprise
st rattler was powerless to stop it and
trimble couldn't see how anyone
could survive
well joining me today
is larry tremble larry
thank you for coming aboard and making
the trips to join us for saw cast number
five how you doing real fine
and thank you john it's your best to be
here today
thank you and you know it just seems
even though that night was 53 years ago
it's still burning fresh in your memory
is it not it is so if you don't mind i'd
like to read just a couple more
paragraphs from the book about that
night on your team
how
that team provided a crucial element
that even though that night we lost 16
green berets the most ever in green
beret special forces history
the body count would have been more
severe
had your team not been up there i wanted
to cover the reasons why in the
book sappers were unquestionably the
elite troops of the nba
sappers received six months of
concentrated and highly specialized
instruction
and assault tactics that involved the
use of stealth and demolitions
their focus was on barrier and defense
penetration they were fanatically
dedicated troops
and now a large number of them were
inside the wire
the enemy lost the attack
meanwhile up on the mountain the enemy
launched an intense barrage of 82
millimeter
mortar fire at fob4 from somewhere
behind st rattler
as soon as the situation permitted
trimble made his way towards the south
side of the mountain
with several of his non-teammates
the nung who had an uncanny ability to
ferret out an enemy's location
even in the darkness pointed silently to
the place where the mortar and its crew
were hidden
on trimble's command
he and one of the nungs fired a volley
of h.e high explosive m79 grenades
at the target
while the others poured car 15 rounds
into the brush
in short order both the attack on st
rattler
and the mortar fire
came to an abrupt and permanent halt
silencing this well-positioned mortar
saved a number of lives
and relieved some pressure on those
in the denying compound
who are fighting hand-to-hand in a
frenzied effort
to keep from being totally annihilated
so larry you were there and that night
um
even 53 years later i remember
how critical that team role was and
uh so
uh
beforehand was there ordinarily placing
recon teams up there as a security
measure just in general or what was the
sop on that beforehand beforehand we we
had had teams up there but they
eliminated them figured we had enough
security i think in the compound
uh we got alerted on i think it was
about the 21st on a wednesday
uh that uh team rattler would move up to
that location
and uh
we packed up everything we did take that
go up to a briefing myself and it went
zero
uh after ed ames
and they told us that they had heard
possibly if there'd be diapers in that
location and that would be probably the
only thing we had to worry about
but they wanted to be ahead of the game
uh we did move forward uh
we packed up most of the gear we had a
m16 machine gun
we also had a couple of m79s we cured as
much ammo as we could and water
we did have a three-quarter ton truck uh
the old beat up one but uh
we used that to help us carry the uh
most of the ammo and the stuff up too
over the base of marble mountain right
but that that three quarter wasn't going
up the mountain
going up
so we had to carry the uh water and and
the ammo up so you can imagine it was
rock steps going up uh
a long way and of course we worried
about possibly booby traps also uh
snipers because of being alerted of that
going up it was kind of like a saddle
marble mountain was uh
we went up
off of route 1
the steps started up and right before
you got up there off to the left we
noticed a big opening it was a cave
going back in
we moved up to where it kind of leveled
off right and off to the left uh there
was just a small clearing
and at that point is where there had
been ropes and previously you know
placed to get on up to the peak where we
was going i would say if i remember
right around 30 meters uh right didn't
pay much attention to it then you know
yeah sure we decided to cash our water
down there because of going up there and
the weight and the weight
yeah so we got that taken care of and
then we did go uh get up there and
set up ourselves made our perimeter
around that location i would say it was
possibly maybe uh
20 meters in a diameter or the flat
surface on the top
a lot of rocks uh
there wasn't a
table there couldn't have been a chopper
come up and actually land because of the
rocks and stuff because when the kinks
occurred they set down one wheel
but they couldn't land completely or if
it was a slick it would put one skid
down but there wasn't enough room for
two skids or two wheels exactly that's
how small that your little security area
was right oh yeah
uh we started relaxed but it was eerie
yeah you could just
i remember just feeling an early feeling
uh not knowing what that really meant at
the time huh
so i took three of the nungs myself
and we did a not that
i'm kind of ahead of myself it was the
next day we did that yeah
august 22nd you went back and did some
recon before all the action started yeah
actually uh we went down we went into
the buddha caves they had big buddhas in
there and they had monks in there but it
was quiet
even the monks were just sitting around
but they wouldn't make no noise yeah
those were monks we were told they were
religious they would be neutral but
we suspected that they weren't or at
least they were more sympathetic towards
the nva and the vietcong that were in
the area that's true
we uh
we did go through uh both of the caves
are just in looked around didn't see
nothing couldn't hear nothing it was it
was quiet
uh and then where it leveled off there
in the middle
of the uh
area where we climbed the ropes uh there
was an off real small opening and we
went in there and
and even as small as i was we had to
crawl to curl up in and get to the top
of where that ledge was
uh
we did a
i could say it couldn't have been as far
as i'm concerned a
better reconnaissance of the area sure
for any spec another enemy or anything
and didn't see any didn't hear nothing
and just you know because by you doing
that you probably did more than a lot of
other teams did because i know some
teams would go up they'd get dropped off
by helicopter
or they would go straight up
but you guys were doing it and this is
out of just from your experience
knowing this area we had reports always
about viet cong envy activity
but on the other hand like your briefing
there's no mention of a major pending
attack you heard nothing about that as
did
majority of people in camp with this
after two people that we'll talk about a
little later
i had heard that also later on uh john
and uh there was none we never suspected
anything like right we had security in
the compound they had k
briefing it up you know down at ccn
but uh
it was just unbelievable you you know
you don't think of things like that
going to happen with the security we had
and stuff
uh i wasn't even surprised once we got
up out there and got settled in and
uh we did i did have the uh
uh
the radio set you know the with the
accordance over to uh the marine outpost
right nearer on the other side they were
on the other side they had a 106
recoilless rifle up there
um
we made contact with them of course meg
contacts the first thing you did when we
got up and got set up was make contact
with uh our compounds that way you could
avoid friendly fire right and uh
particularly with the marines because
sometimes we had recon teams that had
literally contact with marines right
that's true and uh
we uh we got set up and uh
it was a quiet night even we kept alert
uh
one thing i did do though after that
reconnaissance
i was uh i think ames took kind of the
first watch
uh her and did you know they were
supposed to stay awake but did they the
nuns
you know i don't know what they did but
i felt secure enough that uh with the
smallest area we was in sure we had them
lined out if anything was to happen we
could they would wake up pretty fast
sure
i took over somewhere around midnight
and john as i remember
it was around two o'clock and i can't
pinpoint the exact time
there was a because you weren't watching
your clock and it's just another night
on the mountain right and it's quiet and
actually aside from winds and chills up
there
it's a beautiful view of
the china sea
look at heading north to danae you see
the city lights and you know yeah
if you get careless for a minute or two
you just hit you can think about it as a
beautiful scenic site forgetting you're
in the damn war zone with vietcong and
nba underneath you
and then additionally not realizing
that they were prepping for that massive
sapper attack on fob4
right exactly so at some point the your
world exploded so take it from here from
those first couple of moments of what
you're
watching it seeing it down at the camp
and going wtf
like you said it's uh you know it's so
beautiful it was actually beautiful here
because you could see all the lights
denying out the ocean small boats and
stuff like that
even at that late at night you know it's
just it was real beautiful but
when the first explosion i switched
around real fast that
and uh
seen the explosion over there first
thing i did was switch frequencies i had
it set down on our compound that talk
right i'll switch the frequency over to
the marine outpost over there
i had no answer
and i switched back to tell our people i
switched the frequency back
and just as i was calling talk down
there or right close to that time it was
when all hell broke loose down there in
our compound
uh it was a shock
you know at first
and then the marines that outpost got
hit also about the same time you got hit
right they did it wasn't but a few
seconds after it was time well oh yeah
they hit us
uh the point we was that made it real
good they
as you had said earlier they did use
hand grenades mostly because
you know rifle hell i just shoot
straight up over us sure
uh
so we had the advantage up there
but they wanted that point i think they
wanted it badly at the time i did not
believe that or
it never entered my mind how important
that their location was you're a little
bit stunned at what's going on down the
hill oh god seeing the base get hit and
you've been down there two days earlier
sleeping comfortably in the hooch at
night
going to the club air conditioning right
yeah life at a uh base camp which is a
you know you don't worry you're always
told to be on
on uh i guess on guard to a certain
point yeah but my gosh to see that and
you're up there and then before you know
it you're under attack right
they uh they hit us pretty hard right
there they i guess they figured kind of
might be an easy
easy target to take over that point
because they could look right straight
down into the compound right and uh at
that advantage point they could really
put some heavy fire in there
um
as they were hitting us or so they would
uh that's when one of the nuns called me
over him in fact they uh he was our
uh grenadier the one with the m-79 right
we did have to um upper luckily yeah
yeah and uh did you have your salt off
with you
no
no i didn't i my getaway gun right yeah
yeah another story i'll tell you about
time all right
uh
in fact can i slip it in please that's
why we're here
we used to make that you know cut off
the barrel of an m79
go up for the vehicle or the maintenance
building get a
whole muffler clamp what we call it
right and then sew off the back of the
but it was like a pistol right
well you know on the m-79 you've got the
canister rounds you've got a huge round
you've got flesh outs and stuff cs
and cs uh
well i got my map when i got there you
know because most guys did just put a
snap link you know onto the front it was
a good getaway done sure well i went
down to test it out you know at the
beach there along the china beach and
so i reached out to them wow
had a cat not a canister because you
could shoot it with the
you know that flesh hats aren't the uh
it wasn't like an hc anyway and i have
blood just split down
well the only thing worse than that is
like in my time when we cut ours down
the first time we experimented
i fired and got hit with my own shrapnel
my first experience my first
self-inflicted wound uh i think we
learned the hard way didn't we but we
learned yeah but at least at least i'm
sitting and i bounced off your head and
you continued to march right and so so
get back to that night you're on the
ground the two grenadiers open up and
yeah uh
you could see the flash you know right
away that now got hard for me to come
over here saying don't see tunksy you
know i'm pointing down yeah and i seen a
flash
and i grabbed up that and it says fire
on a fire i just started hollering far
on them fine sure and that's where the
mortar pit was where the motor where we
seen the flights we just literally sure
as many 18 rounds as we could put down
there and also uh m16 rounds you know i
had the whole team just pull over there
and start shooting and by that time do
you know how many mortar rounds may have
been fired
no nothing you knew where they were i
because you're defending yourself and
then you hear the mortar going off okay
we understand your mental priority
survive first survive first yeah
i didn't know we got that
i did find out later though that they
had received what they figured was he
rounds falling in there oh yeah there's
no question about that sure and uh he
said they were silas uh
i didn't know that at the time all i was
looking for let's get that crap because
you could hear you can actually hear the
82 rounds
right going over you know so you know
that's going into the camp
um
so after you secure your perimeter then
you move out to that point or did you
have anything else in between
and it was in between because actually
uh
we was hit one more time that night or
that morning
two times they tried to take that
position
the second time was not near as heavy i
think they
decided to better get their act together
before they do because we was littering
them with hand grenades you know right
sure
so the next morning of course uh
hiding our water down at the base didn't
work very well
it was hot as hell even at nighttime i
mean we were literally everybody was out
of water yeah you know
and so i took uh three of the nungs
and i had to think about how many did i
have with me it was three of the longest
myself
decided to get all the water cans and
time to us and had go down and fill them
up with the five gallon can of water we
had down
down at the end of the rope and it went
that area which i think i was saying
around 20 30
yards you know right sure
um
the interpreter being i remember his
name of the nuns oh yeah he went down
first
and then the other
two guys went that was going down and i
was the last one that started down the
rope
and i heard a bunch of babies uh you
know hollering stuff going on
and i was hollered at uh paying them
what's going on what's going on
and he said vcvc they want to surrender
they want to surrender i said why the
hell aren't you shooting goddammit
so no boy here i kind of just let go of
the rope
okay and it wasn't you know just a few
feet
and
when we went down actually i left my
load-bearing equipment up there and they
did too we had all of the canteen
strapped around us and then also uh have
filled our pockets full of magazines you
know m16 magazines 20 rounders what we
had then
um
start firing them i think it shocked
them it was just a few of them i don't
know how many i i just figured it's a
reconnaissance
a bunch of guys going through but i said
let's get them let's get them so we went
after them him
not thinking not thinking nothing yeah
yeah and uh we got right around to where
the saddle started to go down towards
the amphibious mourinho pin right
and uh they were going down that i
hollered up to ames
and hollered for him through my low
bearing equipment drop it down you know
it wasn't that poor
and he dropped it down and we started to
go ahead and holler james i says get the
m60 you know try to shoot in front of us
and so we took off and we know
we acted there was that trail and we had
reconnaissance
the day before
kind of knew the area and about where
that mortar was born we ran up
was chasing him guys and we didn't
actually see him that's why we wanted
that fire sure but we got about at that
location and there's another damn 82
mortar set in there
still with the base plate just
camouflaged a little bit
uh
there was a rucksack there so they kind
of had left that stuff and i guess just
when them well
i says grab that tube just we got the
tube we got the rucksack right and i
said let's get the hell out of here well
let's tell it back they're going to get
the rack together pretty quick down
there yeah
so we ran back and i was hollering at
things at the same time it was we could
holler at each other by voice from where
his location was it was
actually that close the last point of
your
hike to get to the very top yes sir and
uh i hollered that we had captured a
mortar also we had a rucksack uh and to
throw another rope we had ropes when we
went up besides the one we climbed on
then we're stationary ropes you know
where we climbed yeah and they were
bigger
um
he threw that down and started pulling
pulling the equipment back up there
and as we got around there
i i don't think we even took the time to
fill the canteens you know we but we did
we did with a rope tie the uh i remember
getting a can i says get that kind of
water we need that badge yeah and they
pulled it up well on the way up uh ames
had called down to the compound
and uh
taught him the situation that we had
captured some equipment
and uh
that's a rare intel fight you get a
rucksack an enemy rucksack that's always
it was and you know john that actually
it happened so damn fast sure the
reaction we did
but didn't realize what the hell was
doing
i think you know it's just one of them
fast fire fights said oh yeah we've been
and you survived this your adrenaline's
still like flowing in the system there
particularly now you got done chasing
those uh commies right now you're
running back and you got them now was
that the mortar that was firing on the
base that night or was there a separate
mortar i you know we could you couldn't
really tell that i don't know because
actually
uh
i don't think we actually
damaged the mortar when we shoot him 79
i think we just scattered the people
and they didn't it could have been just
the same one you know
um
actually uh haynes had called down to
talk and talks in a a king be up right h
thirty four helicopters yes
king bee yeah yes sir probably love
kingdoms our beloved pilots and king
bees right
and uh
they sent a chopper up
just as we were starting back up the
rope and just about up to the top
whenever uh
they were throwing this stuff on us
earlier i said there's rocks they
couldn't land they could just hover
there you know
and uh aims jumped on the chopper and
and uh says hey where are you going he
says they called they want me to come
down the hill
he says take over and i said it's okay i
got it so and you gave the rucksack
right
he uh he already had that okay
that's that's critical yeah they threw
all the equipment on there
uh and you know the king bee all he had
to do and you know how they used to go
in targets right down on the pad
well
we could watch them from there and they
were unloading stuff but the pilots was
getting out and pointing because they
received a lot of fire yeah uh you know
in the king bee
uh
you know they
we didn't get hit after that
uh the rest of that day
that's amazing it is i and i don't know
whether it was regrouping uh reset i
just didn't know what situation might be
sure but uh that night
uh we did get hit again
and some way they have picked up a willy
peter her wife foster's grenade
was it one of ours do you think
i think so i would think so i i didn't
even know if they had yeah right but
anyway they tossed it up there and a
couple of the guys got burnt with it
real bad wow
uh
about the only way they could do us and
a couple of guys did get hit with
shrapnel you know from downer not
not critical wounds right you know
and uh
so then
uh that was over and we just stayed
alert the rest of the night
uh
the uh next morning it was uh
quiet
but uh of course we recommend for
ourselves being on top of them
still looking down at the compound we
seen guys walking around it it was
devastating that
uh unimaginable to us at the time john
[Music]
one of them days that you don't like to
live to see
and you don't realize it's that bad
until
after over and we start counting the
heads you know oh yeah absolutely
then you realize how bad it really was
we uh we started running out of
equipment
and not equipment uh ammo ammo hand
grenades food
you know we didn't take much with us
when we went
so anyway uh
colonel worm which was our commander at
the compound at the time
had got on the radio and was talking to
me yeah
and uh
he said what do you need up there and i
said well send us up coke because they
indeed say they like coca-cola you know
that says coke beer
cigarettes and as many hand grenades as
you can see in the street
because that was a critical damn piece
of uh so if you don't mind we'll go back
to the book for a second here and
again we're now the morning of the
attack but the attack came
at let's say for our discussion 2 a.m
on the morning of august the 23rd
so now sun's coming up
and ever so slowly night crept towards
day
from their perch on marble mountain
larry trimble and st ratly could verify
the insanity
as well as the extent of the carnage and
destruction
there were simply too many bodies to
count
the supply complex the old talk
were leveled and glowing with fire
while the new talk had been heavily
damaged
a poll of dingy smoke floated over the
compound
it looked like the recon area had
suffered the most extensive damage with
virtually every building having been hit
the whole rolling mess
resembled a harshly lit stage
setting for a major battle scene
outside the bunker barkley and other sf
decided to stay
inside the talk and slowly the gunfire
began to ebb
and the satchel charge explosions
ceased in the northwestern segment of
the base
nonetheless barkley felt it was too
quiet and asked his counterpart to look
around the corner for nba troops
no sooner had he moved to that corner
when two sappers appeared out of nowhere
and charged barclays counterpart
the sf soldiers reflex alone killed them
the two dead nba landed as barclays feet
and he got his boots on their faces just
to make sure they weren't moving
inscribed on the head bandanas of the
dead nba sappers were the words
we came here to die and so they did
and then uh
did you see
with lieutenant colonel barr came in
with his relief element
that came into base later that morning
no i there were so many people moving
around john i
we didn't really see that uh
you know as even as uh i think that
there could have been a possibility if
i'm back up just a tad arab
them guys maybe
possibly get to the top of that point
but i had called
for help down there right when they hit
us right after that attack
and asked to get uh some help
they sent spooky up
and i think spooky at the time was c-130
with a gatling gun right oh spooky was
the the old c-47 c-47 that's what they
were using then but they had mini guns
that's what counts that's right
absolutely and then popped the magic
dragon but they sent up the gatling gun
and uh
i made contact with the pilot he was
calling me
they had given my call sign
and he was calling me and uh trying to
find out where he was
and once you made contact with me i had
uh
you know
told him i put a strobe light up right
with that's like hell there's too many
other lights he said i can't see nothing
no is that right right i forgot that
part i i had john and we was getting hit
pretty hard but that's why i called for
help
you get
kind of you need you you ask for
anything you can get to help me man i'm
in trouble with you
so uh anyway
he couldn't see a strobe like so i had
some we had c4 with his cakes i think
they were two pound cakes of c4
well i took one of them just broke off
pieces and put it on a big rock and let
it i said can you see that
he could he says i got you
and then you directed gunfire from that
right that's why
right he told us he says
if you can pull together all you can he
says because his hair has got maybe a 30
meter radius you know
and uh i'll tell you what and we were
still being hit and at the last minute
he's he said but tell me when
i pulled the people in and that's when
they got
the burp
oh yeah
and there was there was all kinds of
rocks and everything flying up you know
on top of us and uh another people got
hit but i'll tell you what it stopped
the hell out of the nba or zappers or
whatever the hell they were coming right
yeah it did it stopped them that so that
was at what stage of the night did that
happen then you this is you've been
going for a few hours or was it right
they hit us the first time and that was
right when we uh
they had hit the compound right shortly
after that well the second time they hit
us we repelled that and the second time
we hit that's when i called down and
asked for help
i think they had you know uh they had
somebody on the radio then and and they
got a hold of the nang
and got uh that upper i think uh puff
the magic dragon was already up there
dropping uh flares and flares and stuff
uh and then that's when they come up it
was on that second attack on us
yeah cause they again this is getting
back to the morning
meanwhile st rattler was still stuck on
marvel mountain there was no sleep in
sight for them either
a few hours after sunset the nva struck
with small arms fire and a
rifle-propelled grenade
several nva again climbed the ropes in
the effort to reach the team
but the non-recon men killed them
before anyone on team ratler was injured
trimble got on the radio called for air
cover within a few minutes spooky
arrived
after trimble identified himself to the
pilot and crew the airmen asked him to
light his strobe light to pinpoint the
team's location unfortunately the crew
members couldn't locate the strobe
as trimble and genius
and the desperate fellow he was
cuff a hunk of c4 placed it on top of
the highest rock he could find and
ignited it
and off of that
he could direct intense fire the pilot
acknowledged visual contact
trimble pulled his team all the team
members into a tight perimeter hugging
the rock
he then told spooky to work his minigun
fire in a
360 degree circle around the rock
as st rattler hunkered down
spooky opened up and performed his magic
dragon routine
the initial grounds were so close to the
team that they are struck by stones and
debris
spooky continued to walk this fire in an
ever increasing radius
around the team
exterminating anything that was
unfortunate enough to be in its path
after spooky expanded all its ordinance
the air crew continued to circle above
fu before
with
flares
and so that's that moment in time for
you guys
and another attack
and then later you had a radio comma
with warren by that time
he had received the satchel your
rucksack the nva rucksack did he say
anything that was cryptic to you or
caught your attention
not a thing
no nobody told us anything i kind of got
a head there for a minute that's a
really good thing
that describes it quite well what
happened
what that night is like
yeah and you're up there on a mountain
and just the uh
um
the significance of close air support
you know it's just
it's it's this life-saving and then
again had they not been there because
they were able to also direct spooky in
the camp that was another aspect later
on but yeah first and foremost
with you being up there by yourself just
you and your recon team getting low on
hand grenades and ammo here's spooky
and we let spooky march around that
mountain yeah oh my god larry
yeah we uh
you know i i asked him if i had them was
coming back up and they said we're going
to try to replace him with a another man
you know up there and uh
i'm not getting ahead of myself this
time i hope
but anyway that's critical mess because
you're low on food you're low on ammo
right right and they said they would try
to get somebody up there they had lots
of problems herself down there which i
had understood oh yeah i just can't
imagine the pandemonium
and as that next day come you know
what's all part of the morning of the
23rd still
yes yeah it unfolded yeah
that's it unfolded then it was later in
the day the uh
all the nights decided they were going
to leave the hill
and go back to the compound
and uh
so i told bing i says you know i
think
i want to talk to each one of these guys
and see if that's really true yeah each
one of them said that they they think
that they wanted to go you know
and i couldn't talk
and this is kind of funny i don't know
who i taught her they said well take
their guns and all their equipment and
let them go
and i said
you said what
what i think i
might have said yeah but anyway i talked
to each one of the nuns and asked them
really is that what they want to try to
do because i didn't think they'd get off
the hill
yeah yeah and they decided that uh that
was her choice the zero one uh
had started talking to the people and
they decided that's what they wanted to
do
i told him the only thing i'd like for
him to do is leave me all the hand
grenades that they could leave me
because that was my best defense sure at
that location
uh
they took off i told him i'd give him
supporting fire as long as i could see
uh it you know hillary everything you
couldn't really see that well right
and again you
sergeant larry trimble
are alone
on the mountaintop at marble mountain
your little people leave you're the
you're the sole man blowing ammo right a
few extra hand grenades just for good
luck
and that's just that moment i just can't
imagine
feeling like the lone ranger without
tonto
later on i really did
not at the time i didn't i i
i just started resetting claymore so i
did start getting as much
stuff to where i could get to it sure
and uh actually there was actually at
two
locations that they could have come up
the others was just i didn't think they
could make it right uh
so you hit the the obvious areas first
place your claymores
come back with your that cord
have them in a handy location
within
i think
and and you know time i can't give time
but because it's worked uh it is today
it is oh yeah well that too i mean
that's that's old age but i mean even
when you're under fire under attack for
hours by sappers and you're working
spooky bringing deadly fire within 10
feet of your perimeter my god
well i started here i heard a fire fight
going on
and uh yeah on my mountain right i could
not see our people but i had supposed to
have run into trouble well your ears
were key enough that you me you couldn't
hear him now but 53 years ago you could
tell it did between ak fire and car 15
fire
uh
probably i can't remember i'll give you
credit for that larry thank
[Music]
but
i couldn't really help support him and i
would have i you know of course i just
couldn't see him couldn't see him they
uh
it wasn't before long that that being
the interpreter start hollering up
tonksy tuxe
and i said yeah and trunks is vietnamese
for sergeant right yeah and uh
he says we want to come back
can we come back
and i said no
what do you say
it just got quiet i do remember i got
quiet for a while and my thought was
a hundred things going through my mind
like man if they if they was in a
firefight they got anybody captured hell
maybe they're going to try to set it
flip for me because
the other aspect of rt rattler
where did those personnel come from
that's another side of rattler that
we've never talked about before
weren't they trained when they came from
where
uh
the nangs they were strictly nuns so
they weren't they were straight they
were not
that you hoyt no no okay they come out
of truly straight inside gumball go down
there and hurt them
i paid them i've got how much money we
use to pay them more than what the
regular army right arvind would have
paid him right right
but um
it got quiet
you know after a while i i said will you
come up here and bring that zero one uh
the leader up yeah your vietnamese
counterpart right
uh they come up and we talked just they
didn't come all the way up uh
i was telling you
i was still
worried of that
we talked they promised they said we
come back we fight we stay with you till
the end you know
and so they i let them i said okay
uh wow they come up and
i did i called back and told them you
know down the talk told them that uh
they did come back you know so we got
full support you know from them now i'm
sure
and i said what about that american
yeah and the resupply and the resupply
too sure
the other american and you know what
john i do not remember his name i tried
to battle my mind to remember i had i
cannot remember who he was
but they sent him up
and
of course the choppers like i say had a
hoover yeah
and uh
they were pushing off the uh boxes
family and everything you know and the
rations and stuff that says hope and it
wasn't that far up but the american
jumped off
and he twisted his
leg uh you know anyway it really bit
bad he couldn't hike he could not hardly
move you know
so actually he was still a great asset
to me because he was able to operate the
radio yeah keep contact with the uh you
focus on the mission let him focus on
the radio comments right
we did have one kind of a
funny thing happen maybe yeah
yeah this was the next night the last
night okay
i shouldn't say it was early in the at
night
and uh
on the
the
constitution of war and stuff we had up
a protection from the mountain you know
right compound the base they had plenty
of people down there and i seen movement
down there you know going into the water
you know right
and uh
so i called down and they have radial
contact all the way around each one of
them had contact on my frequency up
there
and i told them that they were getting
ready to get hit on that third wall
right there and so bandages powered the
hell out of it you know and everything
oh is that right yes no kidding well
the next morning
uh they sent a team out i was looking
down you know with banana had to be
doctors yeah sure looking down and i
said uh
they were saying well tell us where
they're at
did we get it or something you know and
i said yeah there's they're laying there
down there and so i started directing
them and said hell that's a bush you
know they walked over
the only thing i could figure well guess
what you know all this time and
everything going on
he didn't sleep much and i was taking
the green hornets yeah
uh then they interpret all of the people
was uh
taking bennies yeah
to stay awake with we carried them
uh you know the only thing we didn't let
them carry of course was just rats right
and each american carried
i think five cigarettes is what i wanted
they had the cardboard pack and you had
five ceramics yeah yeah and uh but i
wouldn't let morphine cirrets right
morphing
didn't want them to carry that stuff
because they'd take it downtown when
they got home you know oh yeah a big
time
so anyway i i think that i was seeing
things you know but uh and and
i
i don't talk about that much because at
first that guy said hell man what's
wrong with you tram boys you know but
things do happen oh they do um
and i'd better be safe than sorry
because if you weren't sure is this an
optical illusion or not use you've
directed the proper course of action and
they
either view kong or bush's were very
dead very well could have been indeed
um
so how much longer we up there because
the attacks on the you went up the 21st
the attacks the morning the 23rd
throughout the 24th
and the 26th the morning they were able
to pull us out
oh yeah oh they did send a hatchet for
his team
really
they sent that from the compound i'm not
quite sure what they but they sent that
uh before the nuns took off and tried to
relieve us
up there
they got hit right they got hit they
turned around went back to the compound
uh so that was in between some time john
i can't remember i know
but that's still
indicative that there are still people
in marble mountain underneath you all
because what we didn't realize at the
time was how extensive the tunneling was
right we learned later that they had a
hospital facility there a training
facility a kitchen
and there were several levels that
um we just didn't realize our intel
reports of course let's get back to
intel for a second or a lack of it
because on that night as we've all
learned later
from one of your former teammates gene
pugh
who was on common that night
and uh
not i guess it would be earlier in the
week gene was on but he received a
message saying
attack imminent uh what they called a
flash message which is the top most
urgent priority communication
that came either from the agency or from
another unit
and then bill bill barkley had another
oh no there's another sergeant had the
same message
and then on that on the morning or the
night of uh
night of august 22nd bill barkley so
there's three
messages that said attack imminent
and barkley took it directly to colonel
warren said look at this message and
colonel warren said major moore has
everything under control we don't have
to worry
famous last words
right i did not hear any of this
at all it was not sent up to me
um
i probably wouldn't have changed our
plan up there because we was alert
anyway yeah you can't go too far in that
little spot of land but we had we had
not been uh alerted of right that it was
an
attack uh period you know are going to
happen
and it did
uh
today i feel very fortunate at the time
i
first did what i thought
we were forced on
so when you finally get down the
mountain there was a little surprise did
you when did you learn about the
rucksack and the content they're in
that's when i learned about it
as i got down
uh
we had three and digs that they sent
straight to the dispensary
for injuries
there was an american
that led me down to the hooch my house
had been
destroyed yeah destroyed because lee lee
the dog i had right as she got killed in
that the dog was kia so we should make
it 17 and go back to 17. i forgot the
dog yeah
she was a good dog i got it from
somebody else i'd have never named her
lily
but that was the name she went by but
damn damn good dog you know
and she lived in the hooch and she'd
sleep under my bunk so uh
she was in there when they threw a
satchel charge in there another casualty
of war i would say so i i thought so i
you know
she's a good a lot of
as good as a lot of people
uh good dog
but uh
anyway uh they took me my house and they
did give me a shot to get so i could
breast because my eyes was just almost
like glued open sure you know it's and
uh
they called the medic come down give me
a shot to rest
and i i slept for i don't know how long
her
you know fella dab well
i later on actually uh
when they called me up for a debriefing
you know of everything that happened up
there right after that
as whenever they told me that they had
got a word from the marines that they
would like to see the team on the hill
whoa
no kidding yeah
so uh they sent a three-quarter turnover
picked us up it was at the marina
amphibious outfit yeah sure sent a truck
over because they were on the other side
of marvel mountain right picked me and
the team up the nungs
and carried us back over it carried us
to the officers club and the marines do
live good too oh yeah you know so they
had any officers club right it was the
officer's club
uh they
was going to cook a barbecue for us you
know and
and that took us in and they said that
they'd like to have us all sign their
welcome board you know that they have
what held them damn nungs thought
there's celebrities after that
get to sign their name to it and a good
meal and a good bill and of course what
they wanted to drink was a coca-cola of
course and i got to drink all the
the crispy i could
but anyway john that that was very
uh i'll always remember that as a marine
good brothers oh yeah you know
absolutely always
and then um
so uh
with all that where
did your career in the army begin
um
dictator illinois uh 1956 1956
i uh
i was born 9 19 1939.
i one month later that was
october the second i thanked or right at
that i went into the army
i uh
walked by a billboard up there they used
to have uh right by the post office
that's where they had the recruiting
command for the uh army
yeah and uh walking by there i seen that
paratrooper jumping in out you know and
i said that's what i want to do
and uh then you had to have your parents
sign for you because you're only 17
right and i asked my mother i said would
you sign uh for me i want to join the
paratroopers and she said no you ain't
going and i am paratroopers and
so i said well i want to go in the army
anyway
and i'm kind of saying what i
remember that's how i remember back then
but anyway
she signed for me go in the army
uh well i went to saint louis and then
they took us on down to uh
fort jackson not fort jackson's where we
ended up uh
in missouri
leonard wood
yeah fort leonard where they had us and
assigned everybody to a job
um
i was assigned to go through basic at
fort jackson south carolina
and the first airplane ride i'd ever
took my life is that right yeah
they flew us down there and then of
course through basic uh
they asked uh we had already
been assigned to where we would take our
what they started calling second eight
weeks they didn't call it that then
right they just said your training where
you what you'd be doing was later became
ait right and i i uh
had they of course had a recruiter there
for jump school
yeah of course i wrote a letter to my
mother and said well i'm going to go to
airborne school did you trick her enough
there she didn't realize that the
airborne was shooting i don't know john
i thought i did
you know whatever yeah they they did my
mother and father both come to
graduation jump school graduation
after that i went in and jump school was
then fort benning or brian no no fort
bragg wow but still to drive from
decatur right i think uh one of our
guys there was bloody burns
there's that name recall not for me he
was one of the uh
the cadre that uh run us you know for
dad jump school sure
man that guys could run run run run run
run your legs
off oh yeah but then i uh after jump
school i uh
went on a third packet to germany uh to
the 11th airborne division
um i stayed there until they were di we
went uh
you know we had an episode in
1958 we just got back from hornfield
about the middle of the year
and uh
they we was alerted that was going to be
moving and we didn't know where was
going uh we went to first and fell brook
set up and in the middle of the night
they said load the airplane load your
ammunition your weapon stuff
uh
we was on a c-119
and was one of the last ones to fly out
and they put extra ham on ammunition on
our craft
we landed in italy
and uh got a meal at the uh mess hall
and then we went back flying again we
ended up in
a donna turkey
and uh we had stopped there we was all
out underneath the wings and sure and
the pilot came out but we had a question
to ask him when we was flying
everybody had just taken off their
uh shoots you know
set them back you know we had them made
west underneath them they tried to teach
us that real fast
said don't unhook before you inflate
that damn thing
so
anyway uh
it was actually late anyway it was dark
and we was across the mediterranean was
flying
uh before we got into uh udon and uh
the doors open
uh
red light was on
yeah uh so you know you're all standing
in the door and they've got your
parachutes on and you're ready to jump
well they said hook up and if you can
get a hold of inboxes in the middle
which was x-ray ammo and rations they
started tossing them out the door
uh then after bit you know it everything
calmed down they settled
uh the pilot was losing altitude
and so when he come out you know we was
all underneath the wing and was talking
to him about it
we said well damn man why did why didn't
it it was dark we was jumping before the
jump was in water and it says he was
going to drop us
and i remember him saying you know
we wouldn't have christ with you guys in
it because that c119 would sink like a
dollar you know oh yeah and uh
so anyway another close call
whoa uh
so what was your destination did you
ever find out yeah we went to beirut
lebanon no kidding yes uh we did not
jump in right we air landed
we set up and uh i was in the
it was a 187th and i was in a company
i'm pretty sure and we got we got set in
up at uh jamore
it's up at one of the mountains right on
the border
and they set us up it was a college
up there our university or something a
baby root
uh we got set up there
um anyway we spent uh three months there
and the reason i know it was three
months
was because every uh the old man had
always
you know he cared they carried a safe
with them you know the company
commanders right and uh
we had to
donate you know on payday so much money
because that's when the new uniforms the
green uniforms was coming out the class
a's well we would have to buy a new
equipment you know
no
and when we got back yeah
new year
we found out as we got back anyway that
if you're in it what what they
considered that was a combat zone
even though we was not in combat you
know right so we got a complete new
issue at no charge
[Laughter]
anyway i i didn't mean to get off on
that but yeah so from there
if you go forward and then how do you
wind up getting learning about sf and
what drew you to sf
forces i uh
i went back to the 101st airborne
division i went to vietnam with them the
first trip we went over by boat
uh what year was this 65. uh it is
64.65 right uh we uh
we crossed the international date line
twice
no kidding we had uh the whole brigade
uh on the boat with attachments which i
think was right at around 3 600 people
we was elbowed elbow on there uh
and
uh we crossed international date line i
think took 21 days to get over to bill
oh man we landed in cameron bay right we
debart we started walking
and we would challenge anybody then
because we're so happy to get off that
boat anyway
after i come back i said no more
conventional units for me yeah and uh
they were recruiting for the sf they
were recruiting for the sf at that time
and uh that's
uh right after that's when i went
through and went through
training group training group yeah
wow back to bride go through training
group yes and so then when you complete
the trade where's your mos
11 bravo
sg for german
i could say uh
something like that yeah know
but that was by mos wow so which first
what was your first group assignment
then what year was that 67 now 68 that's
68 yeah
uh well saga
uh
after we graduated uh i got with orders
uh vietnam and of course uh we was going
through the
assignments at the trang
and uh they had signed me to down at
charlie company out there
around charlie company
and right
i'm not sure yeah but
i know as i was walking away i said oh
damned and this guy said heard about sog
by then was that right yeah and i said
man i'd like to patent song
and first nail guy said what'd you say
and that's how i got to sign the song
okay so then you come to fob4 yes you
get there once in the spring then or in
the summer
late spring late spring okay yeah yeah
well so you and i came in country the
same time i landed in april yeah pretty
close yeah we went up that way one you
went to four yeah
we may have even been in the same
briefing larry
probably
yeah welcome to the welcome to the
sequel war from there
and so then um
um then how many years
after your
the tour you d roast you go home
uh 69 and then what what's the next step
in your career because how many years
we've been all together i i spent 21
years i
retired in uh
78 march of 78 uh
with fifth group up fort bragg oh is
that right yes
wow before they transferred up to uh
fort campbell
back in right it was before uh and you
you survived all that rift the reduction
in force period of time that came
through yeah in the 70s that's saying
something because a lot of people after
the buildup by 1970 they went into the
reduction of force
because in
i guess it would be the summer of 69
that the peak manpower was 546 000
americans in vietnam of course
one out of 10 actually was in combat to
rest for support elements yes sir of one
kind or another right and then um
but from that
buildup they had to reduce the reduction
of force which means get rid of people
as many as they can to get out either
force them out
men getting losing rank
grade etc did you get hit up with that
any or were you able to retain your rank
no i was fine so when you retired in 78
your rank was e7
is that right yes
wow yeah
that's that's saying something that time
yeah and then from there 78 then what
that's probably why they didn't catch up
with me
[Laughter]
i uh i retired like i said in seven
eight and i worked for the uh the
government another uh 21 years
uh i was a construction uh safety
inspector
for uh
arizona first i was on the you know the
uh canal that they put through
the uh
arizona there anyway and granite reef i
think they might have called it i can't
remember
uh then i went to california as their
safety manager uh for all the
construction in california all the dams
and stuff sure and then i retired from
that in 1999.
wow
summer is a long line you joined the
special operations association
uh
yes i joined that my number i think is
about
165 or something like that you're real
early yeah they had just been i think
what probably 81 does that sound about
right i think john well it was formed in
1976.
jim butler and a couple other ccn guys
the recon guys put together special
operations association yeah
and uh one of the reasons why i
mentioned it was that while you're doing
everything else
you eventually
became the director for the special
operations association riders
who
over
several years did
numerous fundraisers that raised the
thousands of dollars
for the soa which was directed towards
the bright light fund which was for
helping
veterans to come to
the reunion basically right because
there were some of our guys that just
couldn't afford it so thanks to you
be able to get them to come out in
addition to that um
if they had if they needed care
they could pay for their care person
or whether it's a wife or a nurse right
because there are some key people that
came who otherwise wouldn't have been
able to but thanks to the riders so you
did that for a bunch of years so talk
just that's a little bit of a fun side
light
but it's interesting you know you formed
them up and then yeah each year you had
one or two fundraisers every year as i
recall right uh we did that uh
and
we would bribe once a year together our
first ride was back to the wall
right uh we placed a reef back there and
we'd have a short memorial
and then different states started asking
us to come to different towns was that
right that worked to us i forgot that
part of that that's the way it started i
just thought you all just called said
hey we want to come do a thing
i didn't realize the states called you
up too so all this uh well it actually
wasn't states it was individual
organizations that had heard about us
right and uh in fact uh we went to
branson
uh
bill set that one up for us bill brother
and uh
the guy where we had the memorial we
used to read off the names of the guys
that got killed
and uh everybody would give a flower
uh john i believe you made the one when
it was in california then i d very
touching
and uh
so we had the same ceremony all the time
you know was we would
always honor those guys that got killed
on 23rd of august
after me that was so important sure
still today is absolutely and uh
you know we had the 20th anniversary of
the 50th anniversary of um august 23rd
68
which they had a reunion we attended
that and there we paid homage to those
men yes and for the first time we met
family members of those who were killed
in action that night
yes and it was for quite a moving
ceremony a breakfast and then they
stayed for the whole reunion
and just talking to some of the family
members it was such an incredible
experience but you were a key part of
all that yeah i um
i believe that
bonnie cooper was uh kind of our
she's the go-to lady she was and she
was the secret resource for the soa and
i'm pretty sure there was 69 can
family can that got to go to that yeah
grandkids
kids and stuff like that that's
wonderful
uh if i may bring this up about uh why
we're here
um
men susan my wife was sat in that table
and uh this guy came up behind me you
know and tapped me on the shoulder
and he says larry and i turned around
and i stood up and emily's wife i was
standing there he says you remember me
and i says no i don't remember you
and uh he says when we went through
training group together
training group together right he said
you was a staff sergeant then
and he says
there were three or four of us are kind
of tied in with you because we figured
if you made it well we could make it
then you know
because it was rough back then i thought
that way and uh
so we talked a few minutes and he had
went to vietnam
right after we got our training group
and then he went to work for the fbi as
a criminal investigator
and uh
i said oh that's great that's why are
you doing now
he said well he says i retired but they
called me up and asked me if i'd come
back
and uh as he left uh
we shook hands uh
the wives talked for a minute you know
sure
and uh he gave me one of his coins you
know challenge coins i thought that it
has his number on it but didn't have his
name and damn to this day i can't
remember what it was
but anyway i i didn't mean to get off on
that i think well it was pretty annoying
because even there you had like a
because of your experience and time time
in the army there were men to turn to
you didn't even realize it but they were
following your footsteps to get the
training group which which then was
very rigorous he remembered my name and
his wife said but you're almost every
night talk at the dinner table
as a joke i think oh yes absolutely and
through the soa we have we go back to
our time at ccn fob4 because at the end
of 68 fob4 became ccn they consolidated
the six fobs so ccn was for north ccc
was con cartoon central and south was
the third
and you had some pretty good
memorable experiences there too
with um
some of the men that were there and as
well as some of the men that we lost
along the way and people just forget
that secret war the casualty ring was
formidable and of course in march of 69
with one name that comes to mind is
ricardo davis oh rick carl yeah oh yeah
it's like you and ricardo in my mind
i didn't realize how old you guys were
so i get the ccn i see ricardo i always
assumed he was an e3 or an e4 just a
common guy
so one day we had a formation he's
rearing he's wearing e7 stripes and you
had e6 stripes
yeah you know you had to earn those
things by time and grade so you two were
people i looked up to instantly realize
that you've been in that long
i was just i just had been promoted to a
buck sergeant
and of course i entered your country
unlike you entered the country as a
sergeant or staff sergeant i came in as
a knee deuce so i was a little bit not
as powerful as you but ricardo some of
the other people there
um did you say that you also had that
experience where somebody got a picture
of you with martha ray you could talk
about martha a little bit too as one of
our saints
right i uh i do
have a picture and i didn't realize it i
did not realize whoever gave that
picture but uh
my youngest boy he uh
bradley he was teaching uh
these kids that this school and the
school was for uh
kids that was having a hard time you
know in life and
was their last chance before dribbling
how i think and
brad was riding wearing one of our
writing shirts
and uh the kid says oh he was in the war
what war was that you know and
of course brad told him and said well
that's not me that my father was
in a
and they said well what's his name and
he said larry tremble
well the kids come back to school the
next day they've gotten on the internet
and found a picture of me
martha ray
when i i give her
one of our windbreakers that we used to
have sure and the one zero one break
windbreaker black one zero you right
over the top yeah some had snaps with
the hood right i saw a k bar
oh is that right yes uh
you know i got a whole box of them
k-bars because i told you about that
knife it broke into
uh
yeah that was kind of like the one tom
had made for you right that we got from
the train well that when they threw that
uh my load-bearing equipment down to me
up there on marble mountain yeah
that knife went blue no
well
uh was it made in china i think so
anyway
there was one of the seabees over there
you know and so i made a deal with him
for a couple bottles of booze you know
for a case of k-bars you didn't trade
him one of those viet cong flags that
our people thought that he put ketchup
and gave it to him i know
[Laughter]
that was some pretty good fun days oh
yeah we had our time sir so what was the
event do you remember what the event was
when you were with martha ray you might
explain a little bit yeah
by the way was an actress
who became an honorary green beret from
dozens of tours of coming to in country
working with special forces entertaining
but
sometimes she'd be in baseball he came
under fire and she was a
qualified nurse and she would help out
the medics
doing some of the triage and treating
some of the people and thus became
earned her honorary green beret which
there are not many women that have one
that's true
she was the
colonel martha ray yes indeed what she
gave her they gave her rank and she i
guess she had been in the reserves or
something so she had some legitimate
army rank right it's just colonel like
colonel
yeah and uh
we used to talk all the time you know
her drink was vodka and water
vodka and water yeah
and uh
she used to come all the time up there
and she started bringing this lady with
her frenchie
right and uh
frenchy uh
started working for the underground uh
her
boy and also her husband in germany
during world war two
was killed by the nazis right she went
into the underground and started working
for the uh english you know of jumping
in and
getting people out you know right and uh
that was kind of her history but i guess
this gestapo was waiting on the mona
drops on one time
uh word got out uh she was put in a
concentration camp and
uh when the americans liberated her was
she
fell in love with america you know and
uh so she came in and
you know she got uh her and martha why
met some way and you know i don't know
if you remember john she used to come
frenchy come up to the with martha ray
up to the sag conventions
well yeah those are yeah the days before
i began attending a lot of the
conventions yeah like she came to ccn at
least two or three times during my tour
of duty each time i was either at the
launch site or in a target yeah i never
you know you and ricardo davis and the
other guys all had your photo ops right
and uh she was just an amazing lady she
just loved special forces she would and
you know everybody always say maggie's
drawers you know what every time she
come in she'd bring a little bikini
and they pinned it up behind the bar you
know yeah i remember them daisy yeah
absolutely and of course you know she
she really
got to know ricardo davis everybody lost
ricardo on march of 69.
she came back she was there for the
service i'm told because again i was up
at quan tree and she just wept yeah you
know she really really missed it because
he's such a character
yeah she was she's a
one of a kind woman oh yeah and she left
the space forces and i believe she is
buried at fort bragg correct yes yes
with high honors high honors because
right many women buried there
um well we're we've gone through
anything else going back and looking at
that fateful night of august 23rd 1968
that perhaps you'd want to get covered
or just to reflect on
or things because sometimes when you and
i get talking
like the first interviews i ever did
with you for an article for soldier or
fortune
was different than the one i interviewed
for on the ground because you remembered
more
and then after that there's been a
subsequent follow-up for the sentinel
which is the sfa chapter 78 newsletter
and again every time i interview you
there's surprises so for book four we're
going to put all your surprises together
and redo
that
so if you got anything else larry fess
up right now buddy oh well that you're
going to have to catch big wind
i have to come to ready
yeah wish you at night huh yeah
you know i at one time said that i'd
never failed what the hell i did you
know right right
um
but i did when you talked me into it and
i think that was up at uh jim lamont's
house that's right and we meet you for
me you and bill bill
bill wither where there was no was there
but who was the guy that wrote the book
and common valor
oh bucket bucket
remember bucket he sat with us and had a
drink oh
and we there was four of us sat down
there's two uncommon valors one was by
stephen moore okay this step back he's a
friend he was a cousin or a nephew of
george hunt who ran recon out of ccc
and he focused on ccc missions okay this
is uh somewhat different objection
generally he was there also yes it is we
got all the books we could carry indeed
you know back
i uh in fact i left out of colorado me
and sue was going to go up to uh
that what is that bike ride
no we was going up we was
what is that every year sturgis we was
going to go to steroids okay sure so uh
we've stopped by to see her sister in
colorado where jim lamont called me up
and asked me if i'd come up you know
there's going to be a few people up here
that's how i got to win
uh general simlab went and uh
well eric all of them said
take all the books you can take
oh no uh well bucket had uh
he did all of that
exposing
uh people that
wasn't uh oh remember right yeah um
i haven't talked to him in years but he
was there all right and then we had baby
song baby signs he didn't come in yeah
yeah because i said no he had no no he
got killed
he was
was the author of stolen valor right
co-authored it and it's the most
astounding book
and that detailed uh
stolen valor from so many people to rip
off the va right other vet people that
want to bees that pretend to be veterans
including some really big name actors
right yeah just scumbags his book is
good book fabulous book and he was there
i forgot about john right and i had
because i asked him where'd you get that
name bucket he said my dad mom called me
that everyone i said
they called him buckado
i forgot that part oh yeah we was having
a good time up there oh yeah
a great time well yeah and one of the
reasons we had that that meeting was was
called together was because at that
point in time
it was six years after
we had the uh ccn the communist news
network
and the warner brothers did the
erroneous
uh lies
story about operation tailwind
and so operation tailwind was one of the
most successful sog missions from
september 11 to 14 1970
where we had 16 green berets 120 indeeds
that went in to relieve the cia
and uh
out of that mission
of the 16 green berets there were 32
purple hearts issued
and then on october 23rd 2017
gary mike rose received the medal of
honor right because he was a sole medic
on that and the reason we had the
meeting in 2004 was a follow-up because
they did not offer corrections
and they had a
limited apology
and limited corrections
and they were discussing with jim
moriarty who was a complete stud for us
he was a jim moriarty for anybody who
hasn't had the pleasure of meeting
that young marine to this day he's just
got that full of marine spirit but he
was a door gunner for three tours of
duty with the marines several two or
three of which they were attached to sag
right right because scarface and other
marine units were attached to us
throughout the eight year seagull war
and so jim got to know us and when this
happened
jim jumped in and did pro bono work
supporting our guys suing cnn and
warner brothers and at 2004 they were
preparing major litigation
and then they went forward with that and
they're talking about possible movies
and things like that all of which
disappeared
once some of the court settlements
happened
and they're all top secret so anybody
who got money or might have got money
it was all
without anybody saying i did anything
wrong just give them a large chunk of
funds here but jim moriarty was a stud
on that and of course
now just the side note on jim his boy
jimmy
entered the special forces
became a proud member of the fifth
special forces group and tragically was
one of three green berets killed in
jordan
in november of 2016.
and uh
just
last month i believe or
march jamie was posthumously awarded the
silver star cool absolutely right and
that was jim's only son
and uh so a little sidebar on a sidebar
there but uh
you know he's always been there for the
sf people yeah and he's also recently
worked behind the scenes to help paris
davis who was an officer
get his medal of honor
and when he was in vietnam
amongst other people he saved was billy
wall and during that combat he earned
and was put in for the medal of honor
twice and twice the army quote quote
lost the paperwork oh yeah there we go
yeah
but at their gym moriarty once again
with a couple of other key volunteers um
and
neil thorne who's a national guard who's
helped the special operations
association over the last 12 to 15 years
helped people get awards that they were
rightly earned
but the command elements were just too
busy to take care of that right but
that's another sidebar
so anything else sir upon reflections
here any final words of wisdom or uh
certainly no no regrets but uh or
anything so yeah let's close out here
before we close okay just one thing
please if
i can remember anything else before i
buy the farm john i promise you before
you do your book i'll let you know oh
that's good and i just want to i just
want to thank you for uh uh
being here today and try to open the
door up to the american people of uh you
know the sag which we do have classified
operations today still indeed there are
there are still spec ops going on and we
have special forces teams around the
world
and we can't talk about that because
it's top secret but it's not like
the key thing that people forget about
special forces we work with people to
help them better their lives they're
boring
and the sf model is de apresso liber to
free the oppressed and we live by that
model we do so at this point in time i
want to say all of this sodcast 5 we owe
a big thank you to jocko willink
and his right-hand man echo charles
and uh
without that sponsorship and their
outstanding drinks
like their go energy drinks
we thank them
and as we close out we also want to
thank all of our service members today
who are out there defending our country
one way or another
whether it's the army navy
air force coast guard marine corps yes
indeed and now we have the space force
out there and then we have to add all of
our first responders and particularly
during the last year the first
responders
and anybody that's out in the field
helping our people that are sick
we just salute all of you with that we
close for today
thank you for joining us larry it's an
honor to have you here with us until
next time
so welcome to the to the post show
interview here i'm joined by our our
current mystery man tom the technician
who is uh serves us quite well we thank
him for his
replicating services like echo serves
jacko we have tom the mystery man that
works for us here at sodcast
and so
tom you've been here for the first four
sodcast to be part of our history here
what about number episode five with
sergeant trimble is that a man or a man
that definitely a man oh my god i mean
you're up on a mountain by yourself yeah
you're you're indige just decide
now i'm done
what do you mean you're done
we're not done we got a mission to
complete
but uh i can relate to some of that like
oh we're done no you're you're no no
there's work to do
you can't just leave no we can't no
but uh in that predicament i mean
you have nowhere to go
like you're
up on top people are below you throwing
hand grenades at you
then a white phosphorous hanger dated at
that and then they had mortar decamp on
top of that they're mortaring the people
below you and you
i mean the
it's got to be a feeling of
we need to take care of this but i'm
helpless i'm watching these guys on the
ground i'm watching these guys in that
camp i'm seeing
the chaos i'm seeing it and i can't do
anything
oh not to mention while that's going on
i'm getting attacked so i'm watching
this i'm getting attacked
and then i'm out of water
and there's no warning there's no intel
reports to say attack imminent
uh that they well there was
but nobody let anybody know that there
was an attack imminent yeah the base
commander and his uh his other major
buddy
just said oh no we got it under control
the village is not they're not hostile
not at all oh very good yeah yeah um
you know it'd be interesting to go it
would i think it would be kind of
really interesting to go to marble
mountain and people have done that and
see what it looks like people have done
that spider parks have been back
dan
who was on rhode island later
both of them have been back and uh doug
gottshaw who's now president of the
special operations associate i believe
went back in a separate occasion
and
dan and spider i forget if doug had been
on this but they separate times
met
the the buddhist monks and he went down
they had a whole
i i
i don't want to say a religious service
but it was very spear a spiritual
service where
they acknowledged
all those who were killed on both sides
of the battle yeah and when spider was
there
robert j spider parks who was the one
zero of my team later flew covey
and
on the night of that attack
he came into fob four on night at 22nd
took pat watkins
um
what was he took a nine millimeter
uh
submachine gun with him to go downtown
to the safe house yeah and he missed the
battle but came back in the morning
and oversaw it but the damage and the
and the what had gone on then it did so
help with the cleanup and what not yeah
because your book really outlines you
know on the ground
when you read that and you
you take in the guys that were there
yeah they could take in the stories of
the guys you know sleeping in in their
in the racks and then obviously getting
woken up and then walking down the hall
i could still i could still picture
like literally visualize that but it's
like
you did a great job like telling that
story from the ground and then listening
to this
and listening to
another another vid you know what is it
another another another aspect of it
plus another aspect of stuff that was
missed in the books because it changes
so it's it was interesting to
you know you read the book you get that
kind of sense of what it was like but
then you listen to this and you listen
to
larry talk
about what it was like up there and it's
it's a different it's
it changes everything because
you you now you get that personal
relation uh relationship to what it was
like and it wasn't just you know oh
we're up on top of this mountain like i
didn't realize
how much they went up here then they had
to climb the ropes and then they had to
get this you know and
i don't know if i'd felt comfortable
doing what you guys did like going up on
top and you have tunnels
below you oh yeah and you don't know
what's in them
i mean i don't know how deep they went
in to recon those but i'm guessing you
didn't go real deep but at the same
point what do you know who are the monks
hiding like you guys said the monks
were they for you or were they
against you well they deep down side you
knew they probably weren't exactly but
you just couldn't come out and say that
but then you sit there and you look at
those tunnels and it's like
you can hide anything in there i mean
there could have been a battalion in
there
larry had mentioned
he mentioned the hatchet force that came
back and they couldn't they got hammered
they took casualties i don't know if we
had any kids
and
um
i know one of the i don't know if that
was the effort where one of the
lieutenant actually went into a couple
of the caves and he was kia he had a
hard time getting his body out
was it the hatch force was 40
could be anything from anything from uh
a platoon to a company yeah
and that's so it may have been a platoon
size operation
and uh so on that occasion
and then a few days later um they tried
another effort and again people got got
wounded up there what happened to the
marine that was the one thing i didn't
um
they got
they shut them down because larry never
heard from yeah
the con never came back yeah when he
reached out we assumed they took the
radio oh wow yeah
yeah i wasn't sure on that but i mean
exceptional story i mean again
the courage and
heroic acts that you guys
did on a daily basis
over there is
i mean it's to me it's just unfathomable
i can't i can't i can't
i just can't even think of it in today's
in today's realm of things
one i can't see
i can't see any officer out there who's
willing to sign up say we're gonna send
this one guy
with these
eight indige
up to top mountain by himself or with
another american but then we're going to
take that american and lean there by
himself
the risk that it takes you know that
that
you guys took a huge amount of risk and
everything you did and it shows
a lot of just that internal thing that
you wonder where that is today right
because it's a very few they just had
that movie that came out with just i
anna and i just saw for the first time
but where they put that
like a small company into the valley
and they and they kept getting warnings
you're going to get attacked you're
going to get attacked nobody believed
that attacked that was outpost yeah yeah
outpost yeah i mean so that's that's a
similar like a modern day version of 100
yeah of that and the vlog is 23rd and
then what a horrible you know
place
and who would put them in in the valley
like that without anything above yes at
least you had a mountain but you put
someone up on it yeah they didn't they
didn't even put output they you know
they had no ops you know very little
anything up there and it's that's right
they had yeah two medal of honors
two medal of honors in that yeah so i
mean
they did a good job the that whole film
they did a great job on that film i mean
i'll give it to him on that because
they included some of the guys for that
oh yeah you know and hope
hopefully
hopefully we get to see some movies
on this stuff
oh
we can't depend on hollywood but we can
depend on jocko yes he's getting our
stories out and
and by time this is aired by jocko
there will be a sog
uh prairie fire video game
that will go on market may the sixth may
six which just happens to be my
daughter's birthday so i i can't i can't
forget the date
and it'll be on sale
and uh try one
today being the fifth and all sergeant
it is
my bad
sorry anyways that'll be out there and
we continue to march forward so anything
else that we want to add in our analysis
here tom the technician no uh besides a
little wire loose but you know we'll
figure that out um i think it was uh i
think it went well
that was an amazing story it's great to
see that i can't wait for the next one
because we're pushing i'm already you
know
i'm just going to put a bed here pretty
soon just so i can keep keep up on all
this but yeah
it was phenomenal it's great to meet
larry it's great to great to hear his
story and you know and see what you guys
did yeah amazing man and like i said he
and ricardo davis i was always amazed
when i learned how old they were because
i just thought they were they were young
hard chargers like the rest of us but
they were both senior
senior time and grade you know they were
old hard chargers they don't knock the
age
well on that we will close our post
interview analysis again we thank jocko
and his jocko productions for
giving us the saw cast and as always we
always close out thanking all of our
service members who are putting their
lives online the first responders and
many other people around the world that
are
working to help
make our country a better place
we'll sign off until next time we'll see
you on sog cast 6 in the very near
future